he stones it seems can only be
brandished by things of extraordinary
strength these carriers can use this
stone down entire civilizations like
wheat in a field hi everyone its charlie
you've probably seen the news that
Angelina Jolie is supposed to be joining
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
Eternals movie that's going to be
shooting later this year so I'll explain
who she's supposed to be playing how I
think that the Eternals movie is going
to be invoked somehow during avengers
endgame and post-credit scene because
it's all various celestial related and
up to this point in the MCU we've only
seen a little bit from the Celestials
through the guardians of the galaxy
movies is they talk about the Infinity
stones and we're sort of moving past the
Infinity stones but Thanos is an eternal
of titans so he descends from the
Eternals that we're going to see during
the Eternals movie so even though
they're going to be changing the
foundation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with the plot of Avengers
endgame they'll still be this line of
continuity where you'll be able to tie
all the stuff that Thanos is doing with
the Infinity Gauntlet to the stuff that
was happening tens of thousands of years
ago with these Eternals characters we've
only got a little while left before
endgame actually gets here so we'll do a
new round the IMAX take a giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video about what you want them to do for
the next Avengers movie so yesterday all
the new sites were going crazy about
Angelina Jolie becoming part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe supposedly
she's gonna be playing Cersei during the
Eternals movie who's one of the leads
the other lead is supposed to be her
cousin Icarus in a couple of the other
core Eternals characters that showed up
during Jack Kirby's series so there been
a couple different miniseries that
Marvel has done with the Eternals
characters they've always been super
obscure they've crossed over with the
Thor comics they've crossed over with
the Avengers comics but their comics
have never sold particularly well which
is why you don't see them that much
they're just not that popular as
characters the cool thing about them is
that they're sort of like Earth's
original superheroes the Inhumans didn't
come till a little bit later they were
the Kree experiment regardless of how
you feel about Angelina Jolie she's
still part of sort of like that top tier
level of actor that they've been trying
to get in their movies brie Larson is a
more recent example that Angelina Jolie
is way
way bigger and way more popular
worldwide but you'll of course remember
her from the Lara Croft Tomb Raider
series mr. and mrs. Smith with her
former husband Brad Pitt I know people
like well were they gonna try and get
Brad Pitt now to play another character
in eternals probably not because Brad
Pitt and Angelina Jolie are in the
middle of a very acrimonious separation
so I don't think that they're gonna jump
at the chance to work with each other on
a film together anytime soon she was in
wanted with Professor X before he became
Professor X that's actually based on a
comic book she played Grendel's mother
in Beowulf you may know her from the
Kung Fu Panda series she played
Maleficent she actually doing another
Maleficent movie coming up really soon
she was Alexander the Great's mother in
Alexander so she's done a lot of heavy
mythological comic-book related movies
before so doing the Eternals movie
wouldn't be any different from that and
because of all the Thor movies you sort
of seen Marvel's take on how they handle
big mythological figures Thor Thunder
God Asgardian really more like an
advanced alien race that make themselves
seem like gods because they're so
powerful the plot of the Eternals movie
as far as we know it's just their war
with the deviants the villain of the
movie is supposed to be drew Wiig a
Karissa's uncle I assumed that he'll be
a more evil version of Loki but they
always try to find a way to make people
like this sympathetic the way they've
been talking about the plot makes it
sound like they'll be tens of thousands
of years old instead of millions of
years old like they are in the comics
quick backstory on their characters what
happens is is eternity creates the
Celestials and tells them to garden
eternity itself the universe so they go
all over the cosmos trying to grow
different life experimenting
quote-unquote on planets they come back
after eons to see what's happened to
their experiments if life flourishes on
a planet they'll continue to allow it to
exist but if they feel like it's a
failed experiment they'll kill the
planet so that's what you're seeing in
this guardians of the galaxy scene where
you see the collector explaining the
Infinity stones and you see Isan the
searcher pound the power stone on this
planet completely destroying everything
so in the way that they're using the
Infinity stones to explain how certain
powerful characters get their powers
they might also try to do the same thing
for the Eternals the reason why the
Eternals are so powerful characters is
because their bodies contain celestial
energy so it halts the aging process
making them functionally immortal which
is part of the reason
why genetically Thanos is so long-lived
I'll explain him in a second because he
descends from a slightly different group
of eternals but the Celestials using the
Infinity stones in their act of
gardening eternity in all the cosmos is
just the easy way to so all this
infinity saga these last ten years of
movies together even though the Eternals
is coming during phase four and they're
moving past the Infinity Saga storyline
Angelina Jolie's Circe character also
has some really interesting powers too
she's a class 4 illusion caster so her
illusions have physical form they're so
good that they seem like they're real
you can't tell the difference and she's
a class 5 transmutation master meaning
that she can turn almost anything into
almost anything else but there are
limits to that like she couldn't
transmute an infinity stone into a
hamburger or something like that like if
Galactus came she couldn't transmute
Galactus into a pig she kind of comes
off like a witch two most common people
who don't really understand how her
abilities work but because they're so
long-lived and they're so powerful
people on earth think of them as gods
even though technically they're not
quite the same as the Greek gods they
live in Olympia the Greek gods of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe hail from
Mount Olympus which is actually pretty
close by Kevin Feige has used the term
ancient aliens when talking about them
so if you've ever heard crackpot
theories that aliens created the
pyramids think of it that way so MCU
people are responsible for a lot of
these really big structures and ancient
concepts within the world because we
have the x-men now we could also say
that the x-gene is a result of things
that the Celestials did when they were
creating the Eternals so a lot of that
will just depend on what they do to
change the foundation of the MCU within
the plot of Avengers endgame they've
already said that the movie is gonna
change what you know about reality in
the MCU so it just sounds like they're
gonna leave a backdoor to explain how
all these other superpower people can
exist while the Avengers have been going
along this whole time without us knowing
about it and we said no more surprises I
was really hoping to pull off one last
one
moving to Thanos and the MCU now so
obviously the ages of all the characters
are different in the MCU than they are
in the comics Thor is much older in the
comics in the MCU he's about 1500 years
old
Santos is older than Thor but he's
younger than Odin it sounds like these
new eternals characters are going to be
around the same age as Thor's
grandfather Bohr so the Asgard
would know that the Eternals are on
planet Earth Thor's probably vaguely
familiar with them or he learned about
them in school quick backstory on planet
Earth there are several different groups
of eternals living on different places
on planet Earth the group that we're
gonna see during the Eternals movie are
called polar Eternals the group that
Thanos his father a large of Titan comes
from is from a different place on planet
Earth he's about the same age as Icarus
his father but because they live for
tens of thousands of years they're
functionally immortal Thanos is actually
much younger than the characters that
you see during the Eternals movie so
when you see Angelina Jolie's character
yet Thanos has not been born yet what
happened though is is that a large left
to colonize the planet Titan with Thanos
his mother he was born many thousands of
years later they could wind up showing
youth anos being born in one of those
eternal sequels if they wind up doing a
trilogy but those group of eternals left
planet Earth the ones that we see during
the Eternals movie like Angelina Jolie's
character they stayed on planet Earth so
they would still be around in present
day and I don't think that they cast
someone as big as Angelina Jolie without
trying to get her into one of the future
Avengers movies so I think that they'll
try to find a way to explain how these
Eternals characters can still be around
while all this Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame stuff is going on
without us knowing about it supposedly
they're also including Star Fox in the
movie he Stannis's brother
eros of Titan in the comics so that kind
of breaks the timeline a little bit so
if they do include starfox he might not
be fan OSes brother in the MCU or if
they do want to do the comics they could
just say that he's thousands of years
older than Thanos in the MCU so there is
a way to make it all work but some of
that still speculation because they
haven't officially announced every
single character that's gonna be in the
movie that is why I think that one of
the post-credits scenes for Avengers
endgame is going to be celestial
Eternals related just giving you an idea
of what's going on with them but
obviously Avengers endgame is coming out
in a couple months they're probably not
gonna shoot a post-credits scene with
Angelina Jolie's character there might
just be a visual reference there are all
kinds of ways that you can tease
concepts without actually having a
character or an actor be on screen play
just something really vague that'll let
comic-book readers know oh that's what's
going on so you can explain it to
everyone else this is what they're
teasing big celestial stuff headed into
Marvel phase four they've been do
so much cosmic stuff in the last couple
big movies it would be a pretty easy
slam-dunk for them to use Celestials as
the next big villain of the MCU
everybody post your Angelina Jolie
reactions in the comments below and let
me know what do you think one of those
Avengers and game post-credit scenes is
going to be there'll be more Marvel stop
posting later this week leave your
requests in the comments below
congratulations Dyson Hoover you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to learn what's going on with
all the x-men and Deadpool movies during
Marvel phase 4 and click here for all my
Easter eggs from that brand new Avengers
endgame trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]